think to acknowledge the preliminary
findings at the former saint joseph's
mission residential school near williams
lake
we acknowledge the news of these
findings brings back many
painful memories
back to the service for residential
school survivors and their families and
indeed for entire communities
services are available for survivors
needing support
as they grieve and navigate this tragedy
for indian residential school survivor
society form 1-800-721
for the sultan leyland society phone
1-888-403-3123
these numbers and more information about
support services will be provided as a
background or to our statement today and
of course will be available broadly i
want to recognize the strength
leadership and courage shown by the
williams lake first nations in the
communities of survivors and their
families as they undertake the difficult
but necessary work of telling the truth
about our harmful history and legacy of
the residential school system in british
columbia and with that it's my honor to
introduce dr bonnie henry
thank you very much and good afternoon i
also would like to extend my thoughts to
the williams lake first nation
and
the
all of the families and communities
another 93 possible children who did not
return home
introduce dr bonnie henry
thank you very much and good afternoon i
also would like to extend my thoughts to
the williams lake first nation
and
the
all of the families and communities
another 93 possible children who did not
return home
and my heart goes out to those families
those communities who have been living
with this unbearable loss
and my hope is that this is a first step
not only in acknowledging and grieving
but bringing those children home
so today we'll i'll be talking a little
bit about the uh our latest update on
the covet 19 public health response some
of the changes that are coming and will
be posted
in the coming days and
recognizing as well that we will be very
soon at our two year anniversary
from the very first case that we had
here in british columbia in our first
press briefing on friday
we do continue to see a gradual decline
in our case rates over time
and the leveling off of the test
positivity and as you know
the numbers of daily cases
gives us a sense of trends using that
one piece of surveillance data but we
also have other surveillance data that
also supports that we are on that
downward trend in community infections
but at the same time the number of
people in hospital remains high
and it's the highest it has been in our
pandemic
and it's putting significant strain on
our health care system as our pandemic
evolves and omicron brings these new
challenges we have evolved our pandemic
response and i've talked quite a bit
about that in the last
two weeks
last week we made many changes that i
had indicated in briefings before but it
challenges us when these things are
different and new
as we shared last week and thinking at
the heat map that we presented on friday
we do know that even now with omicron
some people are at much greater risk of
hospitalization and severe illness
and we need to bear that in mind as we
make these changes
the risk factors are clear
number one and most important and one of
the reasons why we are getting through
this wave in the way that we are is
vaccination status we know that vaccines
make a difference a tremendous
difference the other one of course is
age and from the very beginning we've
seen that the older we are the higher
likelihood we have of having more severe
illness and the higher likelihood we
have of having other underlying
conditions that may complicate an
infection with something like covid and
in particular people who have
compromised immune systems what we've
talked about is clinically extremely
vulnerable
they are more at risk even with
vaccination
we also know that with each
vaccine that we receive our risk of
hospitalization goes down dramatically
yes we know that people who have been
fully vaccinated have been infected with
the virus with omicron in particular and
some may question that the effectiveness
of vaccines overall
i want to assure you and we see these
data coming more and more now it takes
time to put these pieces of the puzzle
together when something new and a new
strain of the virus comes on the scene
we now have had
another month of time since omicron came
on the scene and we are seeing more and
more pieces of this puzzle come together
and it shows us the effectiveness of
vaccines and the importance of vaccines
and protecting people from severe
illness
and also now of course there's more and
more data that shows that the booster
doses also protect against infection
even with
omicron we do however need to continue
the number of measures that we have in
place in the community and those also
have been working to try and mitigate
those risks even when there is
risk of milder disease so with that in
mind
we will be extending the bc vaccine card
program through to june 30th
and it will continue to apply to people
over the age of 12.
if we are in a better place before june
30th however we will look to make
adjustments early the the bc vaccine
card program is specifically designed to
address those and mitigate those risks
that allow us to keep certain businesses
and activities open
during the period of the pandemic as we
move through this period it will i
expect no longer be necessary but right
now it is one of those important tools
that we have
as as as mentioned with
has been the case all along with a
sudden surge it takes time to gather and
reassess and assess the data in recent
days there have been a number of
publications and three studies from the
u.s
we've looked at
additional information from ontario from
japan from south korea
and it really tells us right now that
those booster doses give good strong
protection against omicron as well it
boosts up that protection for severe
disease and hospitalization but it also
decreases your risk of contracting the
virus probably by about 50 to 60 percent
so it is not a hundred percent it's not
as high as we saw with all of the other
strains that we see and particularly
that really important protection against
the severeness of delta but it is
important and it does stop your risk of
transmitting to those who are closest to
you as and your risk of contracting it
yourselves
we do know however
that uh that the um i do want to also
mention that people in the clinically
extremely vulnerable groups one and two
the people with compromised immune
systems and we know that we've had a
third dose to get them up to that level
that most of us guess with two doses and
we did announce when we announced our
booster program that they would be
eligible for boosters at six months as
well and i just want to reassure people
in that category that yes you will
receive your invites for your booster
dose at six months
and we know
that people who have immune compromising
conditions and the data from friday
shows us this again
that the risk remains high and you do
need to take extra precautions and all
the rest of us need to be aware of that
and take those as extra precautions as
well we need to follow the public health
orders so that we reduce the risk to
everyone
because we all have someone in our
circle whether it's family whether it's
in our social contacts at work who is
immune compromised who's older who may
have that extra risk right now when
there's so much of this fire is still
circulating
whether we know it or not
we all have those people in our lives
that is why we must all continue to take
those actions we still have provincial
health officer orders in effect we still
have things like our vc vaccine card for
those highest risk activities
and we need to all take those actions
that work our number one tool not the
only tool but our number one tool
remains immunization vaccination with
both dose 1 dose 2 and your booster dose
but it also is things like limiting the
numbers that we're gathering with right
now when there's so much virus in our
community
wearing mass good quality mass when
we're in indoor public settings around
other people washing our hands regularly
staying away from others when we're sick
particularly if we have a fever
and following those important things
like our coveted safety plans that we
have in our workplaces like the plans we
have in our schools like the measures
that we have in place in post-secondary
institutions
this remains so so important right now
as we weather this wave of our storm
today the national advisory committee on
immunization updated their guidance
around childhood vaccines
particularly for those
5 to 11. and you may recall when they
first came up
that
the
the language was around may be offered
well they have strengthened that
recommendation and that is because we
still what we are seeing is that uh five
to eleven year olds thankfully remain at
low risk of severe disease but the
number of children being hospitalized
because of infections has gone up as the
number of infections has gone up across
our communities in addition we have new
and reassuring real world safety data
from millions and millions of young
children who have been
protected through vaccination and so
they have strengthened the
recommendation
from
to say that all children 5 to 11 should
be vaccinated
we also want to uh
this guidance also recommends that there
is continues to be at least eight weeks
between first dose and second dose
that first dose will provide tremendous
protection it's that eighty percent
protection once you've had your immune
system started developing those
antibodies and that will make the
difference for what's happening right
now but we want to make sure that we're
protecting children for the long run as
well and we know that that extended
interval between doses gives our immune
system
a chance to respond and give extra
strength to our cell-mediated immunity
and boost up our our um
our antibodies as well
so it is not only to protect us for now
but also to make sure that we're giving
the best priming of the immune system
for the future too
as we get through this wave
i do want to assure
parents who've already had their
children vaccinated with their first
dose that you will receive an invitation
to book your second dose around the
eight week period and sometimes it's a
few days before a few days after but we
our system is working really well and
you will get that invite
as we do start to see the gradual
decline in cases in our community
combined with the increase in in
vaccination in children of all ages i
will be making some changes to the
restrictions on youth sports tournaments
starting february 1st next week youth
sports tournaments can once again resume
i know that this is an important time of
the year for many
different sports especially team sports
and we've been working with organizers
and with viasport to make sure that this
can be done in a safe way
so that means tournament organizers you
can start planning in anticipation of
this change for next week
right now because of what we're seeing
adult tournaments remain paused for now
today or this week we saw many of our
post-secondary institutions going back
into
on-campus learning again and i'm just
really pleased and proud that that's
happening i know there's been
17 of our institutions who've started
even before now
this really is so important and we
recognize that and i just
know that we've been working hard
working with all the faculty and staff
and student organizations for all of our
post-secondary institutions and we know
that young people have been so
differentially negatively affected by
this pandemic and that these on-campus
interactions and learning is so
important for their growth for their
development for the research and all of
the bright minds that we need to
stimulate in our in our universities and
and colleges and i think this is really
possible because
young people have stepped up and gotten
vaccinated and the high vaccination
rates we have in post-secondary
institutions make it safe
and we've updated in com
conversations in collaboration with the
post-secondary institutions and the
ministry of advanced ed the safe return
to campus guidelines and that includes
the program for
accessing rapid tests and having those
to support safe back to campus
activities so i think that's going to be
a great step forward for many many
students faculty and staff across the
province
additionally we've been working with
the
early childhood
sector and early childhood educators and
who have been in child care operators
who've been working so hard through this
pandemic and i know these changes have
led to lots of questions and concerns
we have last week posted the updated
guidelines for the early childhood
educators and child care sector and
we've been
taking lots of questions over the last
few days and working with them to answer
these questions and address the concerns
and clarifications will be released with
some questions
and answers for people and i know we
have a town hall tomorrow night
to walk through it with many of the
providers and i just want to again
express my appreciation for all of the
early childhood educators and our child
care programs for
the stellar job that they're doing
caring for our children during a very
changing and challenging time
step with the changes that we saw last
week we also shared that our long-term
care and assisted living facilities have
seen a sharp increase in cases
and our seniors and elders continue to
bear the significant burden from this
virus and that has not changed in terms
of people becoming ill however the high
rate of immunization and the high rate
of booster doses that we're seeing
amongst our seniors in long-term care
and among staff
means that we are having a much much
lower rate of severe illness in in
long-term care homes and assisted living
homes and thankfully a much much reduced
risk of things like death
because of this combined with the severe
impacts that come with the measures that
we have had to take to try and suppress
transmission in long-term care homes we
are working very closely with long-term
care homes to make sure that we can
continue to have designated visitors for
every resident who has one
and make sure that we have those
all-important visits continuing even
when we have some cases of covent 19 and
public health teams are actively
monitoring engaged with facilities
across the province to manage these
outbreaks and balance that risk that we
have and
the harms that come both from from
omicron and from the measures that we
put in place
updated guidance for outbreaks
we're working on that now and that will
be posted again in the coming days
balancing that need for restrictions
with the severity of illness that we see
on a case-by-case basis
so i've spoken last week in some detail
about the fact that with omar crime it
has changed some of the tools that we
have used quite extensively over the
past two years
in particular with that shorter
incubation period and what we call the
the generation time so the time between
one person getting infected and or being
exposed and the next person getting sick
and passing it on to others is much
shorter with this new virus strain so it
is no longer viable for us to to be able
to rely on the contact tracing that we
were doing that was really making a
difference
and
it's really that recognition that that
by the time you develop symptoms and
potentially get tested you have likely
unknowingly passed it on to others
previously with different strains when
that was five or six days before the
next uh generation we had time we had
time on our side and the opportunity to
find people and to help them isolate
before they would pass it on to others
that is far more difficult now and why
it is important for us to all go back to
those basics we need to do as we are
navigating our way through our days and
deciding what it is safe for us to do
individually for us and our children
every day we need to continue as i've
said following those public health
orders because they address some of the
highest risk settings that we're faced
with right now
and those restrictions that are in place
but we also need to take collective
actions to reduce risk every day it's
about thinking not only about our loved
ones and ourselves
but those around us who we may or may
not know are at higher risk perhaps an
older relative a colleague that we work
with or a close friend that we spend
time with
let's remember that they're sharing
their risk with us and we share our risk
with them that's why those layers of
protection continue to be so important
so in addition to the continued work of
public health and our teams focusing
focusing on where we need to make a
difference in high risk settings
particularly long-term care supporting
post-secondary institutions supporting
schools supporting
some of those high risk accommodation
settings it means doing what we all
have a role to do
doing what we have been doing as i
mentioned getting vaccinated wearing
masks washing your hands keeping your
groups small and being extra cautious if
you are at high risk it means paying
attention every day to how we are
feeling staying home if we're feeling
unwell particularly if we have a fever
staying away from others and returning
to normal activities when we feel better
we also need to be aware that we have in
our workplaces covent 19 safety plans
that's one of those things that help us
helps us mitigate that risk for people
who have mild illness that they don't
recognize or may be infected
asymptomatically
if we use the the bccdc symptom checker
which has now been updated to help
identify if you likely have covet 19 and
then follow the guidance of when you
need to get tested we do know that it is
important to test certain people
particularly people where you might be
eligible for treatment or you may be
more at risk of severe illness or for
people like healthcare workers where we
need to understand when it's safe to go
back to work
if you are confirmed positive then you
must follow the self-isolation
requirements if you're unvaccinated that
means 10 days for adults
if you're vaccinated or if you're a
child under the age of 18 that's five
days and we know that because we we know
that children have milder illness and we
tend to have
less virus and shed less virus when
we're vaccinated but it's important that
we consider that risk doesn't drop off
to zero after five days but it does
decrease quite dramatically after about
five days in most people so we need to
if you have mild illness and you're
feeling well and your fever's resolved
after five days then you can go back to
activities but it's not back to
everything all at once we still need to
realize that we may be shedding some
virus so it goes back to covet safety
plans at work wearing a mask when we're
around other people in indoor settings
and avoiding high risk settings like
long-term care homes if we can
during that next additional five days
so those are the things that we can all
do that will get us through what we're
dealing with right now
with omicron in the next few weeks
this has been a tough go for all of us
and it has been changing we've gone
through many different iterations of how
this virus has affected us over this
last two years
and we're all tired of covet 19 no one
more than me
and the impacts that the virus has had
on all factors in our life
i think we would all love to be done
with covent
but as much as we would like that
our reality is that kovit is here
with us right now
and we're not yet
over it
so let's offer each other that
encouraging words that warm smile that
connection that kindness
remember that this is ever changing and
that creates a lot of anxiety for many
people
we have more distance to go but we will
see our way through this phase of our
storm as well
friday is as i mentioned our second year
anniversary of the first case in our
first briefing and as i said this past
friday omicron has changed and forced us
to respond differently and this is a
transition but i do believe we will have
a gentler summer that we will get to a
place where we no longer need many of
the the measures and restrictions we
have in place right now
we will also need to continue to support
our health care workers in our health
system and our hospitals
that is where the strain is being felt
the most
and prepare us for our living with covid
in the future in a different way in a
way that doesn't have that dramatic
effects on our lives
so i want to
sum up today by saying thank you thank
you everybody for being patient with
each other for getting through this for
doing the things that we need to do
and being kind and being calm and being
safe thank you
over to minister dix thank you very much
uh dr henry uh today i'll be providing
an update on
rapid test inventory and uh distribution
as well as the impact of
covet 19 the omicron variant of concern
on healthcare workers in our healthcare
system and surgical postponements
first i want to touch briefly on our
immunization efforts which have been
extraordinary more than 350 000 doses
administered
in the last week 110 thousand of those
in pharmacies uh vaccinations for
children aged five to eleven continue as
dr henry has spoken there is
lots of available capacity more than
a hundred and 175
five thousand nine hundred and sixty
eight uh children have now had uh their
dose one immunization uh against covet
nineteen but that number can be higher
we encourage everybody to register today
at the get vaccinated website at one
eight three three eight three eight two
three two three if you want to call in
i'd also note that invitations for dose
two for five to eleven began
as of yesterday with around two thousand
invitations already sent out more than
twenty seven thousand five hundred those
two
invitations for uh children five to
eleven are being sent out this week
based on an eight week interval
and the booster campaign as well
continues full steam ahead it was in
fact not just 350 000 doses but 350 000
boosters in the last week and we pursu
we project similar numbers this week but
i want to say this there are 644 000
people who've been invited for their
booster in bc and have not yet booked an
appointment we strongly or encourage
them to book into our clinics or
pharmacies there's lots of capacity and
i want to say a special note
there have has been an extraordinary
take-up of immunization and if you saw
dr henry's presentation on friday you
know
the risk to those over the age of 70
from kovalev 19 continues to be high
there are 48 000 70 plus individuals who
have received their invite but have not
yet booked a booster it is urgent for
them to get vaccinated as they are much
much more likely to be hospitalized if
they acquire covet 19 and we encourage
them to do that as well as encourage
everybody
everybody who has not received their
dose 1 and those 2 immunizations to get
them today
with respect to rapid tests to date bc
has received 6 million nine hundred
thirty one thousand one hundred seventy
five rapid tests and deployed four
million one hundred and thirty thousand
six hundred fifty six of these tests to
key strategic areas
this leaves an inventory of two million
eight hundred thousand tests
972 355 of which were received over the
last four days
about 558 000 of the current inventory
are not suitable for deployment for
takeaway or personal use
that leaves us 242 000 tests in our
current inventory that are suitable for
self-administered use and we know that
319 860 tests are in transit and
expected to arrive in bc in the days
ahead
this week subject to timely delivery
from the federal government will be
working to deliver over two million five
hundred thousand test kits as follows
three hundred and fifty one thousand for
repackaging and distribution to covet
test sites across bc to replenish their
supply
six hundred and three thousand seven
hundred fifty to replenish supplies at
acute care centers for symptomatic
health care workers and health authority
programs for example emergency
departments
two hundred and ten thousand to
long-term care to replenish and continue
to support symptomatic staff and to test
visitors
fifty thousand to assisted living to
support systematic staff and to test
visitors
two hundred and fifty eight thousand
seven hundred fifty to support rural
remote and indigenous communities
three hundred thousand more test kits to
support k-12 education
three hundred and eleven thousand to
support businesses and organizations as
part of the point-of-care screening
program
as more tests arrive we will continue to
push the areas in greatest need and
expand access across post-secondary and
other areas as identified in the plan we
presented on december 21st 2021.
earlier today the bccdc announced it
will be distributing rapid test kits to
post-secondary institutions for
employees and students with covet 19
symptoms
we have we are also out allocating over
250 000 rapid tests for the child care
sector and are working with the ministry
of children family development to
consider best use and delivery of tests
to licensed child care operators across
bc for testing of symptomatic staff and
to support continuity of their
operations
we'll have more to say about this as our
supply from canada is clarified in the
week ahead
the expected deliveries from our federal
partners have changed somewhat since
last week currently bc expects to
receive 10 million 868 thousand 720
tests between today january 25th and the
middle of february this is a reduction
from the 15 million 719 000 that we were
expecting as of last friday with that
said 10 million is a lot of tests and
we're very appreciative to receive them
clearly the supply of tests will be
substantial but there is continuing to
be flux in orders and deliveries as they
get firmed up by the federal government
it's also worth noting that we've
delivered over 370 000 rapid tests to
long-term care facilities across bc
since last december
since late december i should say these
facilities have a direct line to their
health authority if more tests are
needed and we are replenishing supply to
long-term care facilities as tests
arrive in bc
in fact 210 000 more tests are going to
long-term care facilities this week once
delivered that's over 580 000 tests
provided directly to long-term care
facilities since late december and these
tests are in addition to tests available
to medical health officers if they
choose to use rapid tests to help manage
cases clusters or outbreaks
and now i'd like to take the opportunity
to provide an update on the impact of
sickness on healthcare workers in our
healthcare system first to acknowledge
the exceptional work under very
difficult circumstances of all of our
health care workers in every community
across bc in serving british columbians
in a challenging time
health authorities have been closely
monitoring sickness levels across health
services especially in hospitals
long-term care and home support
i can report that from september uh
january 17th to 23rd at least 17 954
workers called in sick almost precisely
a similar number as to last week
this includes
4252 in fraser health
3265 in interior health 1589
in northern health
1840 in the provincial health services
authority that includes bc emergency
health services
2836 in vancouver coastal
3359 in island health
and 813 in providence healthcare
this is the number of health care
workers affected and does not reflect
the number of days or shifts they may
have called in sick
illness could it be due to coven 19 or
something else
the number of healthcare workers is
relatively unchanged from last week and
down from the week of january 3rd to 9th
and finally now our weekly surgical
renewal update health authorities
reported uh
um reported in the period january 16th
to january 22nd that they had posted on
790 non-urgent schedule surgeries at 71
and fraser health 17 in vancouver
coastal health 401 in interior health
275
in island health and 26 in the
provincial health services authority
no surgeries were postponed in the
northern health authority
accumulatively from september 5th 2021
to today to january 22nd i should say
regional surges of covent and factors
including severe weather patterns have
caused
5895 for
surgical postponements
as noted uh and we've seen this since
compared to the postponements in the
first wave in april and in may of 2020
at that time
there were significantly more surgeries
postponed we are of course wanting to
postpone as few as surgeries as possible
at that time we dropped down i think one
week under 3 000 surgeries which is
a very low number when you consider that
we do the pace of about seven thousand a
week we continue to do a significant
number of surgeries of all kinds across
bc but it is a significant challenge and
the reason why we announce this before
christmas and we're engaging these plans
is support our health care system and
make sure that it's there for everybody
when they need it most urgently
every day now let's say more and more
british columbians are getting
vaccinated whether it's our first dose
our second our third or a booster is an
essential commitment we make to stopping
the rapid spread of covid19 that
critical action we take that makes the
vital difference to where we stand in
our bc pandemic today and where we can
go from here our efforts all of our
efforts together slow the rapid spread
we've proven this our efforts all of our
efforts together result in surgeries
being rebooked we've proven this again
and again
our efforts and all of our efforts will
get us through we know this as dr henry
has said on friday at our briefing on
friday will be two years since the first
briefing since the first case in the
first briefing that was held in
vancouver as you'll recall the bccdc it
has been a long and difficult time for
everybody when
i would agree with absolutely everyone
who wishes it were over and over soon
but these are the steps we can do now
all of us together
our way to control our situation follow
public health orders and guidance get
vaccinated and support one another and
continue to support our health care
system in difficult times and with that
we're happy to take your questions
a reminder to reporters on the line
please press star one to enter the queue
you'll be limited to one question and
one follow-up our first question today
goes to richard zessman global news
and dr henry a lot of the restrictions
have been put in place
are based on the science applied to
delta and i know things have evolved
with omicron but one of the outstanding
ones has been
an impact on events like weddings uh the
industry is frustrated with this i'm
just wondering what in the science shows
you that a hockey game at rogers arena
with 9 000 people and people cheering
and in
large cases people without masks on how
is that a safer environment than someone
uh hosting a wedding event being a
wedding event
yeah you know these are
there's always this how come it's safer
to go to walmart when there's a bunch of
people there and how come it's
it is all about looking at the risk
setting what you're doing in that
setting and i presented that a couple of
weeks ago you know the the whole variety
of things that we look at when we were
talking about gyms for example
so we do know that no matter what it's
those group settings when we're coming
together when we are with people that we
care about and weddings are a perfect
example and i just want to clarify
weddings and funeral services are not
restricted it is the celebrations the
parties afterwards and we know that
invariably those are the settings that
we are seeing transmission not at every
single one clearly but at many many many
and that was what uh it's very
challenging and we've all been to
wonderful weddings where yes you all
start off with the right intentions and
we're sitting at tables but you you're
with people you haven't seen
um it's a positive joyful time and so
at the end of the evening where
you know it
it becomes more of a celebration which
is a wonderful thing but also very risky
right now so yes
there are measures that we have in place
that address in a sort of sequential way
the highest risk settings and then we
put in mitigation things in lower risk
settings and so we look at a hockey
arena it's a much larger space there's
lots of ventilation your space around
people with the small numbers of people
that are allowed in with the capacity
limits
the vaccine card and yes we do know that
some people but when you're at a seat
with very small number of people around
you and a large amount of space it's
much less risky than when you're in a a
nightclub or an indoor venue where
you're
closely with people without a mask on so
it is a gradation of risk and we all
know that there's some settings that we
are seeing a lot of transmission and
there's some of the very same thing
where we don't see any at all so it is
based on risk that has not changed the
factors that we're seeing have not
changed its indoor spaces with poorer
ventilation
less space where
people are
not as likely to wear their mask
consistently those are places where we
see transmission and as we have more and
more transmissible strains of the virus
those become less and less
able to to
they're more and more risky
depending on the setting
richard do you have a follow-up
we're seeing situations where
pharmacies and other places are selling
rapid tests and as you are aware there
is a high demand for these tests and in
some cases
the price of those tests have escalated
quite quickly just one anecdotal uh
piece of evidence that was brought
forward to us was the place was selling
five tests for a hundred dollars a week
later it was five tests for 150
uh what do you think about this sort of
price gouging for accessing rapid tests
and also to the announcement you made
today extending uh the vaccine card can
you uh explain to us the science uh
behind extending it all the way until
the end of june
yeah so i i can't talk about pricing of
of
rapid tests on the private market i will
tell you that there's a global shortage
of rapid tests and we look to our
neighbors to the south where they've
been
trying to get large numbers it affects
the amounts that we've been getting from
canada so i expect that has something to
do with it as well
we will and will continue to make rapid
tests available in those settings where
they are most useful first and if and
when we get to that place where there is
a an unlimited supply we
our my aim is to make sure that
everybody has access to them as as much
as possible in terms of the vaccine card
it has been very effective
again it does not eliminate the risk but
we do know and we continue to see that
if you're not vaccinated your risk your
personal risk has gone up dramatically
with omicron with the amount of virus
that's circulating but also your risk of
passing it on to others has gone up so
we still see that if people who are
fully vaccinated that mitigates that
risk of both getting infected yourself
and passing it on to others and you know
doing that symptom screen making sure
we're not feeling we're feeling well
that we're vaccinated that we have all
of those other measures in place it's
one tool that allows us to to
have
error on the side of of having people in
watching the hockey game or in
restaurants and
it doesn't eliminate the risk but it
absolutely has been mitigating the risk
and i know it's been used quite
effectively by many many people in many
settings and what i said is we're
expanding the program you know when we
put it in place in august we were
looking at
the wave that we were
dealing with at the time and omicron of
course has has meant that it's extended
and changed once again so it is
important right now i've said till uh
the end of june but as i've also said
we'll be reevaluating as we go through
this next few weeks and as hopefully we
will see a decrease in hospitalizations
we'll see a decrease in the the
circulation of this virus in our
communities and we'll be reassessing on
a regular basis the need for all of the
measures that we have in place
minister i don't know if you want to add
to them
say i think
richard is you know from
january 25th to the middle of
february we expect to see receive 10
million 800 000 rapid tests and they'll
be distributed in the way that we laid
out on december 21st and provided
details as they come and we'll be coming
providing details to you as to how
they're being provided around bc
why are we giving priority to long-term
care and to acute care and to schools
and to uh and to certain businesses and
lots of in congregate settings and so on
why are we giving priority because even
though ten million eight hundred
thousand is a lot of rapid tests it's in
fact about two per british columbian and
we have to focus on those areas where
they can most effectively used and
that's what we're
planning to do and that's what we'll
continue to do and we'll continue to
provide detailed briefings as to how
those those are taking place obviously
no one wants to see anybody gouged and
that's something to look at it's outside
of the health care system that's
something that we want anyone to look
we'll obviously be looking at but uh
this is the supply we're getting and
it's significant and we have to use it
most effectively i think people would
expect us to are too and that's why
we've laid out a detailed plan to do
that and we're following that plan
assiduously
next question we go to rob shaw check
news
now that you're extending the vaccine
passport i know you've been asked this
in the past but do you have any plans to
include the third booster dose that's
qualifying for fully vaccinated in the
next
six months assuming that you keep the
passport in place until the end of june
yeah so
i i consider the vaccine passport is the
federal
card program but you know the bc vaccine
card that's in place for the
limited number of venues here
i don't expect to add a booster dose as
being part of it for a number of reasons
one is
not everybody has yet eligible or
has the opportunity to receive their
booster dose and there's still a large
proportion of people although that's
getting less and less by the day who
have not received their booster dose and
or not yet been eligible for it so it
wouldn't make sense to make it a
requirement when a proportion of people
just are not able to get it yet and it
is much more important
for us to make sure that we have that
six-month interval because
we you know we get through this wave i
have confidence in that but we don't
know what's coming next so we want to
make sure we're giving the best
strongest protection that we can for the
future and i'm hopeful that we'll be in
a different place before june and
that will
help us understand what's needed in
terms of
the bc vaccine card
but again we'll be reevaluating this on
an ongoing basis and
my
philosophy our philosophy and my team
and coming up with
the measures that we believe need to be
in place is about the least restrictive
means the least we need to do to make
sure we're finding that balance of
keeping things open as safely as
possible and preventing our health care
system from getting strained
even more than it is right now
rob do you have a follow-up
sure thanks
could you tell us a bit about what the
safety risk difference is between youth
and adult sports tournaments that one is
the in the case of children being
allowed to start operating again next
week and the other stays closed why is
why are they different and what's the
different risk well it is a little bit
to do with risk and it has a little bit
to do with benefit
so part of it is we know that uh
adult tournaments at this time of the
year tend to be
um
a very important social event and that
is of course a riskier situation and
part of it is that you know adults have
the opportunities to do that on an
ongoing basis and there have been
provisions for example for some of the
the uh high impact sports and win
olympic qualifying etc
but we know that sports has a different
place for for youth in terms of growth
and development and future opportunities
so we have always prioritized making
sure that young people are able to
access that part of
these important aspects in their lives
particularly at that age and that there
are
timing limits for things like university
scholarships that become important so
we've taken all that into effect and and
prioritized really making sure that we
can safely restart youth sports
tournaments first
our next question goes to graham wood
glacier media
oh hi hi dr henry um
can you walk me through
the initial reasons as to why
you didn't include masks for kids uh k
to three
and
what you're finding for being since then
in terms of the effectiveness of math
for history
yeah so you know our thinking about mass
globally has evolved over time um and
you know the the
comfort level i think in all of us in
wearing masks and where we need to wear
them and what type of masks and what
things work better and
and partly it's
talking with young people in my life and
understanding that that they can adapt
and that they're fine with it so we
have as you know updated our our
protocols in schools based on what we
were seeing in those schools based on
what we were seeing as
being more and more important over time
i think the other thing that's really
important over time is that the virus
has changed and and i've said this
before when you have more of it
circulating and it's more infectious
each layer becomes more important so as
we were moving into
more infectious strains and having
those those outbreaks it became more
important to have that extra barrier in
place for
for younger students as well
you know there's no it's really
challenging to tease apart is it the
mass that made the difference or was it
because we changed seating or because we
changed cohorts or
so it's very difficult um to
[Music]
understand what proportion of the the
risk was attributable to
wearing masks or not wearing masks
it really is an overall function of of
all of the different pieces that need to
be in place and as the virus changes and
is more infectious or we have more of it
in the community having every single
layer
becomes more important
so i know that's not exactly the answer
that you want but those are those are
some of the
considerations that have gone into it
i will say as well that we look very
carefully at all of the data that we see
around the world around
benefits and harms of every
measure and
the one thing that is clear is that
there are very little harms from mask
wearing in those settings and
children can adapt to it we've seen that
very clearly
graham do you have a follow-up
yeah
[Music]
yeah there's obviously there's a lot to
this um but in terms of the harm you're
saying there's there's no harm but i'm
finding that it may not be studied
enough in terms of the
social
um emotional the hearing the speech the
audiology
uh the ramifications of masking and
um
how long do you think that this can
continue for um
if if these kids aren't going to be
provided respirators for per se
okay you've got a whole bunch of things
packed in there but
you know obviously as i've said all
along
we want to do the least restrictive
means and the least possible so i think
as we move through this wave it's really
important that we take all of those
protective measures we see this strain
of the virus transmitting really rapidly
between people
i don't believe and i don't think
there's anything that shows
that in the community setting
particularly for children
that wearing a respirator so in n95
that's not fit tested gives any
additional protection in the settings
that we're talking about where there are
multiple things in place than a well
fitting comfortable mask that a child
will wear
so
those are the things that we try and
balance
i hope and expect that as we get through
this wave and i've said i expect
that we'll have a gentler summer
having said that you know this virus is
changing and it's spreading very rapidly
in many countries around the world so we
don't know what the next rain is going
to be like whether it'll be milder or
more severe whether it'll be more or
less transmissible able to evade
the vaccine
or previous infections so those are all
unknowns
but i do expect and from history that
we'll see different
patterns over time and that it should as
we have more and more immunity
that will protect us globally from
having more severe strains emerge
but there will be times i believe in the
future where mask wearing in indoor
public places will be important again as
a way of of trying to reduce
our risk of spreading it to others
more so than contracting it ourselves
and it will be one of those things that
we do during that winter respiratory
season
next question bender sagin ctv
hi there um i'm just wondering if
there's an update on the uh field
hospital uh whether some space has been
acquired and given what we're seeing uh
with cases and hospitalizations
it's sort of unclear to me if any
hospitals in the lower mainland seem to
be um on the brink and whether that
field hospital
would be required and even if there
would be enough staff to stop it if
you know if needed
that's over to you minister
next uh vendor we we have uh as you know
uh
929 base acute care beds
we have 2
353 surge beds in our system for
a total of 11 582
and currently in hospital our census in
hospital as of uh end of day yesterday
in any event was about
9050 in other words under the
929 number
now that doesn't mean things are easy in
fact we frequently and pre-covered times
would run well above that number run we
in the number we often talk about in
january of of
2020 we were at about 103.5 percent of
capacity about 9 500
beds at that time prior to cloven 19.
the challenge now is as we've as i've
described that there are a number of
health care workers off sick and we have
the nine and just under a thousand
people hospitalized with covet 19 and bc
so we're making adjustments accordingly
according both to the staff complement
we have and to our capacity complement
but what that tells you is it's not a
field hospital in need we need to
continue to support our staff
should they get sick to be able to come
back to get well and come back and to
support those in our health care system
so with that many beds surge beds in our
existing hospital it's not the beds or
the space it's the people that is the
most significant thing so yes we are we
have space for field hospitals should
that be required but that is an unlikely
possibility but we we did that in in
april of 2020 and we've done that again
recently to ensure that that's there if
required but we are far from that that's
not the issue in our health care system
right now the issue as ever is people
and being able to provide the services
we need and be able to get back as soon
as possible to delivering the surgeries
for all those who've had their surgeries
postponed so that they can get on with
their lives that is critical to us so i
don't think uh the short answer is yes
the field hospital is there
but right now the challenge isn't
additional beds in addition to the
eleven thousand five hundred plus beds
that we have basin surge it's ensuring
that we have uh enough staff there to
take care of the people in hospital
and yet as of yesterday that was uh
about 175 under base bed capacity or
9050.
binter do you have a follow-up
i do just wanted to ask about um kids
aged 5 to 11 in vaccination rates um
i've seen in some places
like some provinces provinces seem to
have much higher rates
how big an impact do you think that
nasty strengthening its recommendation
will have on those vaccination rates um
or do you think there's just
you know maybe people are just not quite
sure if this is the right move for their
child at this point and perhaps that
will lag behind because as you say the
risk isn't necessarily as high as it is
for other age groups
there's a couple of things with that and
you know i look to with awe to
newfoundland and labrador and my
colleague janice fitzgerald there we
were talking actually earlier today you
know where they uh traditionally have
very high rates of vaccination and and
kids there have been vaccinated in
communities all around newfoundland
newflanded labrador so you know we could
learn from how they do it but um and
and
i think there's a combination of things
i was a bit disappointed when nasty
first came out and the language wasn't
that strong and the things that we learn
about from from nasi are you know their
their guidance is directed towards
healthcare providers and there's nuance
in there and sometimes that can
lead people to think that it means it's
not recommended which is not the case
and i think they made that very clear in
their statement today
that they look at the the situation that
they were in when the decision was being
made how much we knew
and you know the fact that at that time
we weren't seeing but a lot of
transmission in our communities
clearly that has changed with omicron
and they make reference to that where we
are now seeing that young people are
being infected and yes the rate of
serious illness and hospitalization is
still very low in that age group
thankfully but more and more numbers of
children are ending up in hospital we're
seeing that here as well
and we know that uh that kids can get
really sick with this even if they
aren't hospitalized it can knock them
out and may it's not an innocuous
illness as i've said so we don't want
kids to get sick the other thing that
that vaccination and you know this is
not what
nasty looks at they look at safety and
effectiveness and
how it should be used but the other
important things that we all have is it
allows kids to to more easily and and
safely get back to all of those
activities that are so important and
when i talk to young people in my life
in that age group they also it's
important for them
to be part of protecting their their
grandparents and older people in their
lives or making sure that they don't
carry that anxiety of bringing it home
to a parent who's going through
treatments or is on medication so i
think there's a whole variety of things
that make it really important for us to
to offer this protection to to children
and i think i'm just happy that nasi has
come out and said that that it is an
important thing particularly now with
what we're seeing
next question we go to derrick penner
vancouver sun
hi yeah you've been reporting on uh
death
uh due to cove did since the beginning
of the pandemic um at this point how
concerned are you that the the deaths
that you're reporting
might not be capturing all the deaths
that might deaths that might be
attributable attributable to cobit 19.
considering the um
statistics canada data on
excess deaths
estimates
yeah and and we've also looked at excess
deaths here in british columbia and my
team has been analyzing those data and
i'll present some of that in that coming
up soon
but one of the things we did from the
very beginning is uh we have a
relationship with the coroner's service
so any uh unexpected death in the
community whether it's related to uh
whether they have a test or not is
investigated for covid so
we are confident that there's not a lot
of people
dying in the community from covet that
we don't know about
and we've seen we've done that analysis
a few times i will say that you know if
anything we overcall the deaths from uh
from covid and
we're looking at the deaths that we had
here in the month of january for example
there were 119
with a date of death in january so i
know there's been more
deaths reported but many
it sometimes takes time for example if
somebody dies in the community and the
coroner does an investigation and the
test comes back positive it may be
several weeks before that is reported to
us so we had 119
people with a date of death in january
and not surprisingly about a third of
them 41 of them were people associated
with an outbreak in long-term care so in
long-term care or acute care and in that
situation it's um
we count anybody who dies within 30 days
of their positive lab test in a
long-term care outbreak so
you know some people had very mild
illness um covid probably had nothing to
do with the reason they died or very
little to do with the reason they died
in some cases and in other cases it was
directly because of covid and if we look
at people in the community the
two-thirds about 78 people in who died
in the month of january so far um who
weren't associated with a care home
overwhelmingly it's about two-thirds
again are people over the age of 80. so
again it goes back to what we were
talking about last week with age being
the number one reason
the number one risk factors for severe
illness and death we have had
four people who were
in their 50s or under including a person
in their 30s and a person in their 40s
who died in the month of january who did
not as far as we know have any
underlying illnesses so it can affect
some people
more than others
as we get older we're more likely to
have
other
underlying illnesses we call them things
like heart disease or lung disease that
put us at increased risk as well and so
all of those things compound your risk
of having some more severe illness and
why vaccination becomes so much more
important in older people as well
so that's a little bit of a summary
i i am quite confident that we're not
missing at least a lot of cases of
people who have died related to covet in
the community
derek do you have a follow-up
yes looking at the
data you release
of status by vaccination
in the unvaccinated
um
people who are contracting covet 19 and
dying
there was a considerably
large number of people over 70
sort of represented in that in that
group
what new strategies are
you
looking at to to try and reach that over
70 crowd
to
get vaccination
what you've learned from this yeah
it is as you know age is that
most important risk factor but even
younger people who are not yet protected
with any vaccine also are more likely to
end up in hospital or have severe
illness or die from covet from all of
the various strains even with omicron so
it is the same thing that we're doing
we've been trying to go
even door-to-door in many cases but
community to community working with
community leaders um getting that
message out to people where they might
hear it uh it goes back to the same
things that that we've seen all along
that there's one of the things
confidence in the vaccine and there's
some people that
don't have that or don't
believe that they need a vaccine which
is you know unfortunate and there's a
small group of people that we probably
are not going to convince
there is uh
and the other part is confidence in
safety and we have more vaccines coming
of different types that may help for
some people
part of its complacency people don't
feel that it would affect them that
they're fine that they don't need it and
so that's something we try and address
by
putting out the information around who
is most likely at risk and then
convenience so making it easy for
somebody to get that vaccine and anybody
anybody of any age who is going for has
made that important decision to get your
first dose you can walk into any clinic
any pharmacy that has vaccine anywhere
in the province and get your vaccine
now think about it today it's going to
make a difference in getting through
this next few weeks but it's going to
make a difference for how we're going to
be able to live with this virus and
whatever happens next to
over to minister differences between
that category and younger children is
that there's actually very little uh
regional difference derek there's a very
high level of immunization over 70 in
the northern health authority interior
health authority in all of our health
authorities across bc i think it's close
to uh 90 percent in the interior in the
northern health authority i think it's
about 88.89
there and obviously province wide is 93
which is a very high level of
vaccination 93 of people over 70 have
got their first dose 91 percent plus
have their second dose and of those 91
percent about 85 86 of those have got
their third dose and so what i'd say
today to those people first of all the
45 000 people who've received
invitations to book who are over 70 for
their booster dose
receives an invitation to book that
group of people has already received two
doses so they are
they are by definition interest in the
vaccine now is the time to get that
additional protection and if you need
any more evidence that was provided by
dr henry last friday i don't i think
i'm sure there will be people including
your family doctor including pharmacists
people in the community who can provide
that to you with respect to the small
group of people uh over 70 or and over
60 who have not received their first
dose we just have to continue to make
the effort to let them know that any
time any time someone in that category
wants to be vaccinated and our hundreds
of locations uh across british columbia
are any locations the pharmacies are
giving booster doses but hundreds of
locations across bc they can get
vaccinated today if you're in that risk
category and there are some and we just
have to continue
to drive that we saw the impact of the
delta variant for months and months and
months on unvaccinated people how they
had to be flown in many cases
hundreds and hundreds of miles from
their home to get critical care in many
cases passing away right
and so uh people need to get vaccinated
first and second dose we just got to
continue to tell them that it's
available to them that millions and
millions of people more than 10 million
doses have been administered in bc
uh so far that across the country uh
significantly more than that i think the
numbers more than 80 million across the
country across the world in the billions
these are some of the safest vaccines we
have and we're here
ready for you if you ch today is the
best day to choose to get vaccinated
we have time for one more question we'll
go to bell puree cbc
uh hi there uh in english and in french
please dr henry um we're wondering about
rules for non-church choirs in bc under
the current guidelines if you could
clarify please if such choirs can
rehearse in person right now like if
they have all the safety protocols
vaccination masking distancing would
such a rehearsal be allowed under the
current public health order yeah there's
no restrictions on choirs at the moment
there's the the coveted safety plans
that are required but
no we haven't made any distinctions
between singing groups in any setting
but obviously there's you know space and
there's we have guidelines about how to
do it safely
mask wearing
over to minister dicks
[Music]
yes please um the sub variant of omicron
is it in bc and if so what does that
mean in terms of the provinces the
response to the pandemic and english and
french please
yeah so we have had a few cases of the
uh
oh
s 4.2 i think it is
we are i think our first detection was
about two weeks ago a very small number
so it's not a significant
uh difference right now and there's
still me
a whole lot we don't know um we have
seen in the uk particularly where
they've seen it in pockets
that there is
probably
increased transmissibility
but whether that translates into any
other parameters that are different
there hasn't been enough of it certainly
not here not in canada
to really see any impact we're not
seeing it
in you know we've been following our my
lab team has been following it really
carefully and
we're not seeing it taking over from
omicron as we saw omicron take over from
delta for example so it is i think very
similar to what we saw here where you
get
regional differences in variants
if we look back at delta for example we
had um regional ones that were here in
western canada you know 25 and 27
that were different from um other places
and that just is because the virus
mutates a little bit in different areas
geographically
when it's spreading that rapidly so
yet to know really what the overall
impact is going to be or if any